let's talk about just how badly the
markets were hammered yesterday take a
look at this dow hit a huge 10 percent
loss the worst one-day plunge since the
financial crisis of 1987 this what
you're looking at there is a 2,300 point
drop that represents trillions of
dollars in value in people's retirement
accounts and elsewhere president Trump
asked Americans to be calm saying the
markets would recover and his comments
came as aides negotiated with House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi on a plan to help
people who have already taken a
financial hit Paula Reid is at the White
House for us Paula good morning a lot of
people hoping this deal comes through do
they have it yet we have some details
from the House Speaker in a letter to
her Democratic colleagues Tony she
revealed that this deal will likely
include free testing for the virus paid
emergency leave enhanced unemployment
insurance and food assistance all of
this meant to provide immediate economic
relief to those impacted by the virus
and the house could vote on this bill as
soon as today we've resolved most of our
differences and those we haven't moved
continue to come to a conversation
because they will obviously be other
bills House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
expressed optimism last night after an
all-day negotiation with administration
officials over legislation aimed at
blunting widespread financial damage
from coronavirus family medical leave
it's about unemployment insurance Pelosi
has been working with Treasury secretary
Steve minuchin to hammer out the
specifics including paid sick leave
yesterday the president warned the
Democrats may try to pack the bill with
unrelated provisions though he didn't
offer specifics it's an accusation the
Democrats rejected if giving infected
workers paid sick leave is a goodie
then God helped those who think that the
president's Oval Office address where he
announced widespread travel restrictions
on Europe along with economic aid
proposals failed to boost chaotic
financial markets the Dow plunged more
than 2,000 points yesterday the biggest
one-day drop in over 30 years
as the president sought to downplay the
turmoil the White House also said he
will not be tested for coronavirus days
after coming into close contact with an
aide to brazil's president at mar-a-lago
who later tested positive for the virus
let's put it this way I'm not too sure
but Senator Lindsey Graham who is also
at mar-a-lago during that time announced
yesterday that he is self quarantine
while he awaits the results of a virus
test and Graham is just one of several
lawmakers close to the president who
have self quarantined after coming into
contact with someone who tested positive
for the virus but the president has said
he has no plans to do the same and just
this morning we are learning that a
senior Australian politician who tested
positive for the virus was in Washington
just last week where he met with
Attorney General William Bar and the
president's daughter Ivanka we have
reached out to their offices to see if
they plan to take any precautions
Michelle
Paula we shall see